good
morning
good morning everyone
we meet here today to
discuss hamas's terror attack in Israel
and the humanitarian crisis in Gaza as
EU leaders met yesterday in an
extraordinary European council meeting
the alahi Arabi Baptist Hospital in Gaza
was bombed and hundreds of innocent
lives were lost the devastation of a
hospital is horrific and
unjustifiable and we must ensure we
continue to shed light on what happened
as the tragedy in the Middle East
continues to unfold it is once again the
innocent who are forced to pay the price
we must remain clear that protecting
civilian lives must keep being a
priority we cannot lose sight of the
humanitarian consequences this has
always been our core message so this
house remembers the victims as we keep
pushing for a way forward in the region
I will now give the floor to minister
Alvarez for the council after which I
will give the floor to the high
representative and then the president of
the commission Minister the floor is
yours president of the European
Parliament president of the commission
High representative
ladies and
gentlemen this morning we woke up to the
news of the atrocious attack on the
alali hospital which has left which has
cause hundreds of Palestinian victims
hospitals and civilians cannot be a
Target the suffering of the civilian
population of Gaza needs to
end we
also are deeply moved shocked by the
terrible terrorist attack that Israel
suffered on the 7th of
October which caused over 2,000 dead and
200 hostages and we call for the
immediate and unconditional release of
those
hostages we would like to express our
solidarity and support to the victims of
uh to the families of all victims their
loved ones and the friends of Israel and
Palestine I'd also like to express my
condolences to France Belgium and Sweden
for the terrible attacks suffered during
the last couple of days we need to
preserve cohesion
tolerance
and understanding in our society because
that is what Europe stands for this is a
very serious
situation and Europe needs to be
faithful to its principles supporting
the fight against ter enaging terrorism
and acting to support the civilian
population we need to fly the flag of
international
humanitarianism and we also need to fly
the flag of flag of Peace that's what
our citizens expect of
us and so do our friends and partners
across the
world
we firmly without ifs and butts condemn
these acts of terrorism and violence B
barbarity cannot Triumph we recognize
Israel's def right to defend itself
against this terrorist
attack this defense defense needs to
take place with the most scrupulous
respect for international humanitarian
law the civilian population cannot be a
victim we need to allow humanitarian
access to Gaza we need to ensure basic
supplies for the population water
electricity food
medicines we need at all costs to avoid
escalation in the humanitarian crisis in
Gaza our friends and partners across the
world expect the voice and actions of
Europe to be raised and for us to act in
in accordance with that desire we cannot
allow the forc displacement of hundreds
of thousands of people we have to we
must at all times distinguish between
terrorist objectives and the civilian
population assistance and cooperation
from Europe to the Palestinian National
Authority and the people of Palestine
shouldn't be interrupted in fact it
should be boosted and therefore the
commission announcement to of the
tripling of humanitarian assistance is
very important that's what our citizens
expect and that's what our partners
across the world expect with that goal
Spanish assistance will be further Prov
providing a further 4 million EUR to
Palestine by the end of the year added
to the 21 million already provided
humanitarian
principles need to be emphasized
clearly in the same way as we affirm and
continue to affirm our condemnation of
terrorism and Israel's rights to defend
itself against terrorism because that is
precisely what
distinguishes nations that love peace
from terrorists we need to differentiate
between Hamas and the Palestinian people
and the N Palestinian National Authority
we shouldn't confuse Hamas with the
legitimate leadership of the
Palestinians the Palestinian Authority
has for a long time been Europe's
partner for peace Hamas does not
represent the Palestinian people during
these terrible moments we must at all
costs avoid the regional extension of
the conflict Europe and Spain are
committed to peace and stability in the
region our number one goal needs to be
maintaining peace and stability in the
West Bank and in Lebanon the situation
in Lebanon is of particular concern this
is a fragile country the UN for Force
commanded by the Spanish General Lazaro
is doing extraordinary work in very
difficult circumstances to comply with
its mandate and maintain stability in
the region Europe needs to stand should
shoulder-to-shoulder with Lebanon basing
ourselves on an agenda of peace and
stability we need a vision of Lebanon as
a state which is the necessary condition
for the people there to be able to face
the
challenges that they face that they have
we cannot allow anyone to make use of
this tragedy for their own
ends but we also today need to start
thinking about the day when this SP new
latest spir of violence ends we need to
put an end to this tragedy which has
taken place too many
times we need to
find a solution for once and for all the
two-state solution Israel and Palestine
living in peace and security one next to
the other
and this requires a definitive agreement
in line with agreements that have
already been signed and parameters
agreed since the during the conference
in Madrid once we overcome this crisis
we need to move forward with this agenda
urgently emotions are running high and
sometimes these emotions are
contradictory and it's precisely because
of that that we need to be particularly
responsible and particularly careful
with regard to what we say and how we
say it when we say it
too Europe firmly condemns terrorism and
violence and we'd like to express our
solidarity with the victims without
distinguishing between their religion
and nationality Europe is mobilizing to
promote firm humanitarian action based
in the Universal values of humanity
Europe needs to act together to demand
that this tragedy is not repeated and
this will only be possible if we can
offer the Palestinian people and also
the people of Israel a perspective based
on a credible and definitive peace and
this requires a two-state
solution the Israeli State and the
Palestinian State living together in
peace and security that's what the
peoples of the region and the world
world have wanted for decades I firmly
believe
that our friends in the region and our
citizens expect Clarity and firmness
from the European Union a firm
commitment against terrorism against
violence a firm commitment to peace to
Justice to
humanity and we need to come together
with all parties and with our Arab and
International Partners to ensure that
this genuinely is the last time thank
you thank you very much Minister I give
the floor now to the high representative
for foreign affairs yes Borel you have
the
floor president of the parliament
president of the commission
minister ladies and
gentlemen These are times of high
emotion feelings are running very
high we need
to call to the voice of reason here we
need to move past the emotions that are
caused by the tragic events that we've
been
seeing we've all firmly condemned the
describable horror of the attacks
suffered by
Israel the attacks against the civilian
population which left so many
dead that have affected so many
defenseless people when they were
celebrating
life and they suddenly found themselves
faced with
death let's say it
again let's condemn these attacks again
and let's say that of course Israel has
the right to defend
itself anyone attacked in this brutal
manner would have that
right I think we also stand together to
say that the right to defend yourself
like all rights has limits and these in
this case are marked by international
law in particular International
humanitarian
law all of this is clear and we can
repeat
it but repeating
us will bring us
nowhere yes we condemn these terrible
terrorist
attacks but I think we also have to
condemn the
civilian
victims
that we we have in Gaza now there are
around 3,000 of them because condemning
one tragedy shouldn't prevent us
speaking out against
another we condemn the terrorist
attacks but that doesn't stop
us showing our feelings for other
victims these are tragic
times and I think that at this time the
European Union needs to base its
response on four principles firmness
Humanity
consistency and a
proactive political attitude to the
conflict being firm begins with a clear
condemnation of
Hamas and as the minister said they
should not be identified with the people
of Palestine for us Hamas is a terrorist
organization and they've shown that
we're quite right to call them that with
their acts of recent days Hamas has been
boycotting any effort to make peace it
stood against un resolutions it stood
against resolutions from the Arab League
which provided a possible path to peace
between Israel and
Palestine Hamas wants to eradicate
Israel from the map they don't want
peace they want
destruction but
it's becoming impossible for the
Palestinians
to achieve a fair peace they're also the
victims of
Hamas but we can't make the
Palestinian
people and the inhabitants of Gaza can't
be made responsible for the terrorist
actions of Hamas being firm also means
calling for the release of the hostages
and this links in with our
second principle for Action which is
Humanity Wars Al so have rules Wars are
terrible
things and what we've
seen this bomb bomb explosion in the
hospital which we don't yet know to whom
should it should be attributed is
another terrible manifestation of what
goes on but War has to be carried out in
line with
International rules and we've said it in
other contexts cutting water water
supplies and food off from civilian
populations isn't in line with the rules
of War there's no water coming to Gaza
now over 3,000 dead over a quarter of
them
children we cannot make the people of
Gaza responsible for the a terrible
actions of Hamas the third
principle political
coherence and I think it's fair to say
that all of us agree on what I've just
said we reject
Hamas and we want to see International
humanitarian law respected by all sides
we want to see attacks against
defenseless civilians end regardless of
where they are and we need to ensure
that the actions of member
states are in line with the common
action of the European Union and we need
to ensure that EU policies are in line
with what we want to see and this raises
the issue of assistance to the
Palestinian
Authority and the issue of humanitarian
assistance to the victims in Gaza and
the decision of the president of the
commission to multiply our humanitarian
Aid by three is a good example of this
political coherence unfortunately
obviously humanitarian assistance needs
to get into Gaza and it can't at the
moment because all ways in are closed
thep I foreign minister has asked again
and again for the
bombardments against infrastructure to
stop so that humanitarian Aid could go
into
Gaza the fourth
principle is the one that we need to
invest most political energy into I
think which is a proactive attitude to
resolve the
conflict I was in Gaza in
2008 during the attacks that took place
then I've
now observed four Wars like this one and
I firmly believe that if we don't stop
the cycle of violence it'll happen again
in a few years time we need to end this
conflict between Israel and pal
Palestine because peace between Arab
countries and Israel which is good
news doesn't automatically bring peace
between Israel and Palestine which needs
to be achieved
an Israeli
reservist who was called up said to the
press that the most powerful Army to
defend his country would be
peace while there's no peace there'll be
no Army that's powerful enough to
guarantee Israel's
peace but peace will not come about
automatically peace has to be built we
should recognize that the International
Community of which we're a part has not
done everything necessary to ensure that
the Oslo agreements agreements which are
now 30 years old be
implemented we've on a daily basis
called for a two-state solution but as
the UN
stated what are you doing to achieve
that apart from calling for it since
Oslo the
number of settlers in the occupied
territories has multiplied by three and
the geographical area for a possible
Palestinian state has been cut to a
series of nonconnected
areas the
solution seems far away and it looks
difficult to implement but we don't have
any any alternative
if there aren't two states there'll just
be one and how would people live in this
single state how would people live
together what would the conditions for
life
be we have one solution so we need to
mobilize our political energy of which
we have a great deal in Europe to build
it normalization with of relations with
Arab countries is not
enough and with this attack it's
possible that Hamas wanted to provoke an
Israeli attack which would make it
impossible to have normal relations
between Israel and Saudi Arabia that may
well have been one of its strategic
objectives it wasn't simply a crazy
attack it's a strategy to prevent moves
towards peace we've been working with
our special Envoy for the Middle East
Sven kman we've been working with Jordan
Egypt the Arab League Saudi
Arabia to relaunch
a process that can lead us to this
two-state
solution we need to recalibrate and
increase our efforts in the United
Nations there are 60
countries all of them in favor of this
solution so today we should commit
ourselves to this and this would be the
best way of honoring the dead on both
sides we should commit ourselves to
building peace which requires political
a political framework that has already
been agreed the UN resolutions necessary
already in place all it needs is a
political boost which Europe can make a
contribution
to in the security Council today we'll
be debating a resolution presented
yester Yesterday by Brazil which will be
voted on today and what will
be what we vote on in the security
Council and the way in which we
communicate on the conflict is is going
to determine Europe's role in the world
for many years to come this morning I
heard the
mosque of Alazar in Egypt and uh there's
a great deal of concern now because what
they said shows that we're moving
towards a conflict between the Muslim
and Christian worlds and we can't have
that because Security on our streets
depends on us preventing that
geopolitics depends on us preventing
that conflict we've made massive efforts
to preventing the conflict moving
further to being extended towards
Lebanon I've spoken to many
ministers during recent
days in Aman we achieved achieved a
joint communication between the
countries of the gulf and the countries
of the European Union and I think think
it's that communication that should
guide our action
humanity and a political commitment to
moving out of this solution and building
a lasting peace that's what we should be
doing thank you presentative I give the
floor now to the president of the
European commissiona
[Applause]
V Madame President dear Roberta High
representative JP Minister
Alvarez Hamas Terror has plunged Israel
and Palestine into a new spiral of
violence last night a senseless tragedy
has shocked us all a hospital in Gaza
Sheltering hundreds of wounded people
was turned into a hell of
fire the scenes from Al Ali Hospital are
horrifying and
distressing there is no excuse for
hitting a hospital full of
civilians all facts need to be
established and those responsible must
be held
accountable in this tragic hour we must
all redouble our efforts to protect
civilians from the fury of this
war and let me express my
condolences to the families of the
victims of the terrorist attacks in
Brussels and Aras
tragically we see that terror is
resurfacing
again it is also Terror that brings us
here to this debate the heus terror
attacks of Hamas on
Israel what we have seen in the
kibuts is pure
evil the blood witness of horror the
burned
houses the abandoned children's toys
there no child will touch ever
again Hamas terrorists slaughtered over
1,400 men women children and babies in
one day for one single
reason because they were
Jews just living in the state of
Israel with the explicit goal to
eradicate Jewish
life Israel has the right to
self-defense and life with international
law Hamas are terrorists and the
Palestinian people are also suffering
from that Terror and we have to support
them and there is no
contradiction in standing in solidarity
with Israel and acting on the
humanitarian needs of the Palestinian
people I have visited Israel many times
in my
life but this time
I saw a nation that is shocked to the
core I was struck to hear the same
request from all the people I spoke to
from president hatuk prime minister
Netanyahu all forces in the unity
government from families of the
abducted they all asked for
solidarity and clear
words and this is the least we can do
for the people of Israel
this horror calls for a United response
from us as human
beings as Defenders of a free
world as Europeans where hate Terror and
racism have no place Europe stands with
Israel in this dark
moment this is the essential starting
point and I believe it was important
important to pass this message of
solidarity in person in Israel just days
after the
attack only if we acknowledge Israel's
pain and its right to defend itself will
we have the
credibility to say that Israel should
react as a democracy in line with
International humanitarian
law and that is
crucial to protect civilian lives even
and especially in the middle of a
war we first have to
listen if we want to be listened
to and indeed during my visit I
discussed Israel's efforts to protect
civilian
lives there can be no hesitation on our
side Europe will always be on the side
of humanity and of Human
Rights
allow me to update you on our work to
address this dramatic situation and the
broader crisis that Hamas has
Unleashed let me begin with the
humanitarian situation which is getting
worse by the
hour humanitarian Aid must urgently
reach
Palestinians this is why we have decided
to immediately triple our humanitarian
Aid to civilians in Gaza and we have
launched an EU humanitarian air bridge
to Egypt to bring life saving supplies
to humanitarian organizations on the
ground in
Gaza the first two flights are taking
place already this
week carrying humanitarian cargo from
UNICEF we have deployed our staff and we
are working with un agencies to
ensure that this Aid can reach those in
need the European Union has always been
the largest International donor to
Palestine and this will not
change but as the situation on the
ground
evolves it is also
essential that we urgently and carefully
review our financial assistance for
Palestine EU funding has never gone to
Hamas or any terrorist
entity and it never will what Hamas has
done has nothing to do with the
legitimate aspirations of the
Palestinian people so it was good to
hear president abas clear words that
come came out on Sunday
evening my second point is about the
regional
situation Hamas actions have major
geopolitical
implications we know that they risk
affecting the historic R between Israel
and the Arab
countries but there is nothing
inevitable inevitable in
this instability can be
contained dialogue between Israel and
its neighbors can and must
continue so this time of war must also
be a time of unrelenting diplomacy
a moment to engage even more
closely with Israel and with other
countries in the
region I have been recently talking to
several Arab
leaders including the King of
Jordan the president of the UAE as well
as the President of
Egypt all were very clear about the
importance of our EU
funding and the European Union with its
massive funding we are the largest donor
has not only leverage but also has a
stake in
it and thirdly we are seeing a rise in
anti-semitic incidents including here in
Europe synagogues have been
vandalized hate speech and fake news are
spreading at worrying speech
speed and this is something that we
simply cannot accept it is our shared
responsibility to make sure that our
dark past does not return we have to
protect Jewish life in
Europe in these years we have put the
fight against anti-Semitism and all hate
crimes at the heart of our
action thanks to our Collective work on
the Digital Services act we now have
laws to take down illegal content
online and contain the spread of
disinformation and we are now using them
for the first time ever we have already
launched an investigation in relation to
X formerly known as
Twitter they must comply with the
obligation to counter the spread of
terrorist propaganda
and hate
speech because in Europe there is no
place and zero tolerance for hate
whether online or in our
streets we have also stepped up our work
to ensure the physical security of
Jewish
communities we have already increased EU
funding for the protection of places of
worship such as
synagogues and at the beginning of the
Mandate we propos to add hate crimes and
hate speech to the list of EU crimes
that must be sanctioned all across our
Union our proposal is still blocked by
some member
states but it cannot wait any longer it
is time now for member states to act and
to move
on Europe's history is a history of
diversity Jewish values have shaped our
common European
values among
others Jewish culture has for centuries
enriched our common European
culture and this must continue to be the
case European Jews must be
free to we Kea or Star of David in our
streets and to light our cities with the
candles of hanuka in their
windows and every European must be free
from
fear we must make good on Europe's
promise to be United in
diversity to be a safe place for all
Europeans honorable members this is the
moment for for all of us to come
together to join forces Against Terror
in all its
forms and to do what is
right I will go now back to Brussels to
join a commemoration ceremony for the
victims of the recent terror attack in
Brussels I thank you for your
attention thank you very very much and
now we go to the speakers of the
political group starting with the Epp
group president Manfred
[Applause]
beber president of parliament commission
High representative dear Minister dear
colleagues why do we have today's debate
on October the 7th Israel was attacked
Israel was attacked in B kibuts 120
children women men killed parents using
their bodies to protect their children
Israel was attacked during a festival to
celebrate peace 250 young people killed
Israel was attacked in shops in streets
at home more than 2,000 people victims
women being raped and paraded as
trophies including people with European
passports in their pockets as 20% of
Israelis do Israel was attacked but also
Europe was attacked the European way of
life was
attacked Israel was after the h
Holocaust the promise the Jewish people
can live safe in safety and in peace and
now Holocaust survivors were dragged out
of their home being abducted and held
hostage the images of media broadcasted
since Saturday are the ones that make us
put our hands over our children's eyes
this is the evil phase of terrorism the
brutality of Hamas recalls the worst at
atrocity of Isis Hamas terrorists
attacked a party in Israel as Isis
attacked bakalan in Paris we see in
Israel what we saw in Paris reason full
inhumane attacks against freedom and
terrorists spread like a virus in France
now a teacher killed in Belgium two
Swedish citizens killed the virus of
terrorism is also back in
Europe and it's a moment when we are
where we are tested and I tell you these
terrorists made the same fatal mistake
like all terrorists do they
underestimate the power of democracy and
the will to defend Freedom colleagues
these are days of mourn for the victims
and hope for those still in the hand of
Hamas but these must also be be days of
firm determination we must be Crystal
Clear we stand with Israel no hesitation
no excuses no butts in this in such a
critical moment in such a critical
situation Europe has to stand together
and that's why I thank Gela ferine for
her trip of Last Friday to Israel I have
to be honest I was a little bit
surprised that it took 10 days for the
European Council to have an online
meeting 10 days in such a moment and uh
dear High representative dear Joseph I
respect you personally very much you
know this but in a moment when our
neighborhood is on fire and we know
about the geopolitical importance of the
region blink is traveling to Egypt and
Israel and our high representative is
traveling to China in such a moment and
I was told that in the last four years
you never went to Israel to do talks
there and try to establish a peace
process in a solid way so that's
why it's in a way a lesson learned that
we have to come together and Define a
common European approach for us as EP
some points are key first we are on the
side of Israel second we are fighting
against Hamas against terrorism not
against the Palestine people third we
are ready to support with humanitarian
Aid and even with additional money as OA
feline proposed it we care about every
victim in this tragic conflict fourth
not any scent of EU money must end up in
the pockets of Hamas or any other
terrorist group Fifth whoever supports
the terror of Hamas and hisa is Europe's
enemy we have to rethink also our policy
towards Iran six it is unbelievable what
happened on social media during the last
days Hamas propaganda glorifying Terror
Without Limits the killer of Brussel of
Brussels was online explaining why he
was killing innocent people our youth
listening online to these kind of things
this must stop this must stop
immediately Zuckerberg and must musk
must finally stop being the megaphone of
hate messages and the seventh point we
Europe we must activate now our tightest
screening mechanisms to make sure that
no terrorists enters Europe through
migrant routs dear colleagues it's a
moment where we are tested we have to be
together I thank also Roberta metsola
for her trip to Israel our position is
Crystal Clear We Stand by Israel's
promise for Freedom peace and
democracy
thank you Mr Weber and now uh for the
snd group I invite the presidenta Garcia
perz to take the
floor the barbarity of Hamas
deeply moved us no cause can justify the
murder of innocent people we feel the
immense pain of the Israeli people
and the terrible suffering expressed by
the families of the
hostage who are here in the hemicycle
today s yonathan Noah we will not rest
until your families return
home and we will we have no better way
of helping Israel than saying that we
will not rest in our search for peace
and
uh we'll also have to look into the
massacre in the hospital yesterday in
Gaza with over 500 Palestinians men
women and children
murdered Mrs veline as well as showing
our Union solidarity with the Israeli
people which of course we have to do and
you did
that we should recall remind Mr
Netanyahu that crimes cannot be fought
with other crimes the worst thing was
the language of his defense minister
when he called the inhabitants of Gaza
Human animals now I would say to Mr n
Netanyahu that his
ultimatum for a million Garin to leave
their homes in just a few hours was
totally
unacceptable did you Mrs V recall remind
him that there'll only be a long-terms
peace when the inhabitants of Gaza and
the Palestinians have hope ladies and
gentlemen millions of people are in
danger and the European Union cannot
continue to commit errors such as
suspending all Aid to Palestinians as
proposed by commissioner
vaheli we have an obligation to call for
international mediation to call for a
ceasefire free the Israeli
hostages and also open up a humanitarian
Corridor to Egypt it's not time for
ideological battles or to apply double
standards Israel has the full right to
fight Hamas and to respond to the
terrible attack of the 7th of October
but it has an obligation to respect
international law and the murder of
civilians in Gaza cutting water food
medicines and also the ultimatum
which displace the population are
violations of international humanitarian
law ladies and
gentlemen following the centuries long
persecution of the Jewish people and the
murder of six million Jews by Nazi
cruelty the Jewish people achieve their
dream their own State the Palestinian
people also have a right to achieve
their dream the right to their own State
a Palestinian state that can live in in
peace with the state of Israel because
peace is always possible and if possible
peace were possible after Millennia of
war in Europe it can and must be
possible in the Middle East too and the
responsibility of the European Union as
a power that exports peace is to act
together to contribute to a peaceful and
fair solution although that may seem
impossible now we need to build build a
free Middle East without hate a Middle
East where walls are taken down and
where weapons fall silent we need
schools hospitals housing all these
things a Middle East that we can call
home for its citizens it's been 30 years
since the Oslo agreements were signed
and at this time it's important to
recall that the only path to peace was
shown Us by Rabin a labor prime minister
he sacrificed his life for peace and
today his words need to guide us moving
forward in the peace with the peace
process as if there were no terrorism
and fight terrorism as if there were no
conversations on peace thank you now
give the floor to Stefan S president of
the renew
[Applause]
group
dear colleagues
president the suffering uh in the world
has CH un settled our continent once
again the absolute barbarity of the uh
atrocities by Hammer against um Israeli
civilians have shocked us uh terrorism
has hit us once again and we uh stand
with the Israeli people just as they
have stood with us through terrorism I
want to say with as firmly as possible
on behalf of my group there is no D
doubt uh whatsoever about the
qualification of the crimes and as
designation of Hammer as a terrorist
organization where um our um Jewish
families are threatened in our
homes and it is our moral duty to say
and uh we uh
need if there is ambiguity then there
will be responsibility for that as you
have
said it is important uh to look at how
this affects our society there is a
Temptation at the extremes our
responsibility as Europeans is to have a
clear Words which are in line with our
values and our
responsibilities the resolution that
we're going to vote on has to be uh in
line with the gravity of these
challenges and uh we would
uh say that this has to be the basis for
the action being carried out by the EU
first of all U uh
condemnation and a call for the
unconditional release of uh the
hostages and uh
we uh would also uh pay tribute to those
who are here today uh on behalf of these
people and we also uh need to guarantee
safety in line with international human
rights that is the topic of uh this uh
debate which was approved in the
conference of Presidents by all of the
groups and then thirdly the need to
ensure the protection of uh Palestinian
civilians in the Gaza Strip we are
shocked by the um bombardment of a
hospital uh there is not one Village or
city which is more valuable than other
and we call for the establishment of a
humanitarian Corridor and the tripling
of Aid uh to uh refugees and fourthly
the EU needs to support uh every effort
that will lead uh to uh two-state
solution uh with two uh Democratic
states living in peace that has to be
our political iCal aim uh around this
consensus we have to Define our
actions and the president of the council
uh the president of the uh commission
the high
representative uh your words uh commit
Europe and this uh resolution and the uh
meeting which took place yesterday
between the me the heads of the member
states I wanted to say that um a random
comments made over the past few weeks
need to come to an end um Israelis and
Palestinians need a United clear Europe
uh which brings together all Europeans
on a clear position we succeeded for uh
Ukraine and we should concede succeed
for all of the international crisis that
we face and uh the resolution sets out
the
uh demands of
Europe because geopolitics is not a
playground it shouldn't be partisan it
is the protection of our populations of
our values and if we want to be uh a
positive uh player in the crisis uh then
we need to be at the height of that
challenge now give the floor to the
co-president of the green group Philip
lamber
nothing absolutely nothing
can justify the barbaric acts committed
by
Hamas deliberately killing civilians
taking children women and men hostage
what this terrorist organization
committed are crimes against humanity in
line with its chief goal the
obliteration of Israel we condemn them
in the strongest possible terms and I
stand here in the name of the green CFA
in full solidarity with the victims and
their loved
ones as well put by us author Frank
Herbert atrocity has no excuses no
mitigating argument atrocity never
balances or rectifies the past atrocity
merely arms the future for more
atrocity yes Israel has the right and
duty to defend its citizens in full
compliance with International
humanitarian law this means that the
response to Crime cannot be more crime
and that atrocities suffered do not
provide a permission for
Revenge Israel's legitimate fight
against Hamas is turning into the
collective punishment of two million
Gaza half of them are children trapped
under an ilal Siege they are either
forced into an impossible relocation or
is being killed by sahal attacks as more
than 3,000 were already no less than
Israeli victims Palestinian Ian
victims deserve our full
solidarity dear colleagues the word is
tearing into the abys the European Union
Must Stand United in calling for an
immediate ceasefire so as to allow the
creation of humanitarian corridors and
the safe return and unconditional return
of
hostages we must be unanimous in our
efforts to demand the respect of
international humanitarian law by all
actors we must collectively step up our
efforts to relaunch a political process
that will make a two-state solution
viable there's no other choice if we
want Israelis to live in security if we
want Palestinians to live in dignity and
if we are serious about ensuring their
coexistence for there will be no peace
until terrorist organizations such as
Hamas are
neutralized there will be no peace as
long as Palestinian territories are
legally occupied and Palestinians rights
denied and their resources
confiscated there will be no peace under
Democrat until Democratic institutions
are firmly restored and anchored there
will be no peace until Palestinians and
Israelis are both free to live speak
move work love as they wish in safety
regardless of their Origins and
beliefs share colleague for
conclud colleagues to
conclude as an
Israeli author
said the divisions in the Middle East
are not between the Jews and the Arabs
they're between the modist and the
extremists between the pragmatist and
the Fanatics we need to unite our forces
in defense of life and against our
common enemy this seems difficult at the
moment thank you see
and I now give the floor to the to
representative of the ECR group bertan
[Applause]
rouson president commissioner
Minister
colleagues the horrific actions of hamus
have shocked us deeply they uh forced us
once again to look at uh the harsh truth
Israel faces a terrorist organization
which respects no one and
nothing what we need to do is to be
Crystal Clear we need to provide
unconditional support to Israel in her
fight against Hamas but we must also
look to
ourselves has the EU done enough uh to
uh put an end to terrorism and the
answer to that question is no we
transferred Millions to the Palestinian
Authority while this Authority
facilitates
terrorism by paying handsome salaries to
family members of terrorists who have
been killed for instance and uh what are
to we what are we to make of water pipes
paid for by EU funds which are then used
to make
bombs this is why I appeal to you
support ourn to ensure that any of the
subsidies which are paid are tied to
very clear conditions of course help is
needed but Hammer aggression cannot
happen without consequences I give the
the floor to Jordan Vela for the ID
group thank you Madame President
president of the European Commission on
the 7th of October Israel was struck at
its heart and suffered the most
murderous attack ever on uh the
state 199 hostages in uh
Gaza this uh shocking
attack uh has uh horrified our societies
and it shows that we must not drop our
guard before the threat of terrorism and
islamism we must not yield to 21st
century
totalitarianism and yet hamas's ideology
is already present in our
societies this is not so much uh a clash
of civilizations as a barbaric attack on
civilization Israel will demonstrate to
the world its ability to uh react and
its reaction must be targeted must
respect international law there will
never be impunity for such barbaric
action Co president of left group
manob share colleague dear colleagues
yesterday evening um Gaza saw the
unthinkable a hospital was struck and
destroyed behind its walls there were
children and um health workers it was a
hospital where a uh life is to be
protected many lost their lives it's a
Carnage onethird of the people who have
been killed are children we have to call
things uh by their name these are war
crimes and uh the Palestinians are
trapped under Israeli
bombs given this humanitarian crisis
every single minute counts a an unending
spiral of violence has started since the
barbaric actions by hamers in this
context man Madame vandel and I regret
they you didn't wait for the um uh
meeting of the president of the group
you have one responsibility which is to
um um Fly the flame of peace and say
that every life counts but you did not
do that worse when you went to Israel
you usurped the European voice and gave
a a support to the
act the legitimate defense it is not a
right to
um
attack you cannot have a collective uh
punishment of citizens for crimes they
have not committed they are not canon
fodder and uh Madam Vander how did you
give unconditional support uh to netan
without saying one thing about a
ceasefire uh of course we stand with uh
the Israeli people who have been uh
attacked uh by hamus on the 7th of
October uh hamus um sowed Terror and um
uh killed over a thousand um innocent
people and took uh 199 hostages but uh
we need to condemn these atrocities
every uh Israeli citizen deserves our
compassion and uh support when faced by
these barbaric actions
um uh but Mrs V Deion we can only find
that
um
appropriately what about the
bombardments of uh Gaza where is
Humanity when you're cutting off water
and refusing health care and uh when
people are called Human animals and when
a million of them are told to flee
without knowing where they're going to
go for decades the oppression of the
Palestinian people it's humiliation and
its colonization have been uh covered by
a complicit Silence by Western countries
Gaza was already uh an open prison now
it is Hell on Earth and if nothing is
done soon it will be a cemetery Mrs
Von um when uh the situation is so
difficult you need to uh confirm today
as uh the uh un Secretary General
antario gues did this morning the only
uh valid objective is a sea fire so we
call for the immediate release of the
hostages and the opening of humanitarian
corridors and uh certainly not uh the
ending of Aid to Palestinians as your
Commissioners uh proposed everything
needs to be done to ensure that there is
a lasting peace uh through a two-state
solution which is defended by our
Parliament peace Madame felion calls for
recognition and
coexistence history is
watching if we fall in the Trap of I for
an eye for an eye everyone will end up
blind thank you to Fabio masimo Calo for
one
minute thank you president
colleagues the terrible images of the
barbaric terrorist attack committed by
Hamas on innocent people will remain
before our eyes forever Israel has the
clear right to defend itself but it also
has a clear Duty as a democratic state
to fully respect international law in
order to defeat Hamas terrorists it's
not necessary to carpet bomb the guard
as a
strip to enable CI civilians to be
evacuated it's not enough to send down
fliers from Planes you can't bomb the
entire Palestinian people to in order to
do away with Hamas they are the hostages
of H of Hamas and as always it's
innocent people who are paying the price
for this
war over a third of those killed in Gaza
are children innocent children like the
innocent children of Israel who were
murdered by Hamas these are innocent
children not hardened terrorists who
should be the targets of any response
Europe Can't Stand By and Watch while
this unprecedented humanitarian disaster
unfolds we need to ensure that
humanitarian Aid can enter Gaza we need
to ensure that civilians are looked
after Gaza cannot become a worse hell on
Earth than it has been until today thank
you Lopez white tono two
minutes thank you very much uh dear
president of the commission for your
leadership once again like during the K
like during the war on Ukraine again you
have spoken for all of us not like
others that they're here only for a
political gain or for sectarismo
well today we have a historic
responsibility now this is what's going
to happen tomorrow tomorrow the
parliament will have to decide whether
or not it condemns terrorism we're going
to hear a lot of speeches today all
different points of view whatever
tomorrow however when we
vote we will see who stands against
terrorism and who doesn't that is the
single Criterion quite apart from
ideologies fighting terrorism it
requires no half measures unfortunately
we learned that in
Spain we have all these sweet sounding
speeches but we're talking about people
who've murdered people they've raped
women they've killed innocent
people
we shouldn't be hearing what we hear in
the streets in the corridors of the
European Parliament
now almost on the anniversary of the Yum
kipur War Israel has once again been
attacked in a cowardly and brutal
manner there are people who refuse to
condemn what happened and that's
incredible to see but not only do they
do that they accuse and insult those of
us who condemn terrorism that's nothing
new for those of us from Spain we've
already seen it we've lived through it
but we will defeat
terrorism we will defeat
it because
defeating terrorism is in line with the
principles of the European
Union we're seeing these principles
denied in the streets of Europe and we
know who's behind this conflict Hamas
Hezbollah Iran's proxies which is an
extremist regime which can't can't
accept the normalization of relations
between Arab states and
Israel it's their manipulation which is
destabilizing our European Democracies
we can't allow that to happen and we'll
make it clear in tomorrow's resolution
thank you our next
speak isino
Picola thank you Mr President first of
all I would like to explicitly condemn
the brutal attacks of Hamas on Israel 11
days ago that was the deadliest day for
them since oops sincere condolences to
the families of the victims and full
support for all efforts to releas the
hostages Terror must be stopped but this
debate wouldn't be complete without a
broader context an important distinction
between Hamas and other terrorist groups
from Palestinians deprived of most
essential resources and used as a human
shields in this brutal conflict as even
hospitals are being attacked
international law must be applied and
international criminal court should be
in charge most urgently we have to do
our best to ensure that humanitarian
corridors are functional and to support
the work of un unra and all
humanitarians workers there it's
essential of course that the European
Union start speaking with a unified
voice thus beginning to live up to its
geopolitical Ambitions thank
you thank you Madame vman the floor is
yours thank
you thank you very much president
colleagues Mr Burell what is happening
is u in Israel is horrific uh hundreds
of uh dead in kibot is and what happened
yesterday is a a an attack on a hospital
where uh healthcare workers doctors
children are and
uh the the death of Dominic barar in
hate and and then and then uh the death
of uh two uh football supporters from
Sweden in my uh own City
Brussels full support for Israel and uh
stop
Israel that's what and sanctions
Pro katar and Iran uh when are we going
to have U sanctions against the uh
horrific regime in Iran and not just the
symbolic 100 or so people on the list
and I was going to address uh Mrs fer
Laden but she is not here
uh Hamas is not the Palestinian people
um people live in um the West Bank and
Gaza but they don't necessarily support
hammer and we need a new peace process
and uh
and we need to make sure that we have a
Democratic states and uh the supporters
of this approach are in the majority and
that is uh uh what we need to do that is
true geopolitical
Union
colleagues every uh tragedy is also an
opportunity and opportunity to uh build
peace and uh uh fight against hate and
you have our
support
Mery Mr
CH is it too much to ask that barbarism
and atrocities be unequivocally
condemned even when someone may feel
close to the CA in whose name they are
supposedly committed
if we don't first and foremost have a
human response to victims of Terror we
are lost the attacks by Hamas and the
holding of hostages are acts of
terrorism and it sads me that there are
some still reluctant to condemn them
these atrocities hard the Palestinian
cause which is a legitimate cause that
does not deserve to be put into the
hands of
Fanatics we are still terrified by
yesterday's Massacre in the in the Gaza
Hospital such criminal acts have to be
investigated and per perpetrators be
held accountable the indiscriminate
killings of innocent civilians and the
immense suffering inflicted to civilian
population need to be condemned and
stopped demanding respect for
international humanitarian law does not
weaken our condemnation to Terror it
rather strengthens our commitment to a
rules-based world even in a world full
of
hatred we are facing an extremely
difficult situation no diplomatic effort
has to be spared in order to avoid an
even bigger humanitarian crisis and to
prevent a regional spillover of the
conflict humanitarian corridors need to
be put in place now hostages need to be
released it is urgent to deescalate in
the perspective of quickly achieving a
ceasefire these are days of rage and
sorrow but sooner rather than later
those who reject violence and one peace
will need to be rewarded there is a
conflict pending resolution for decades
and the only way out is through
international law and adjust peace
terrorism is also fought by genuinely
and tirelessly working for peace now
with the bombs falling this may seem
like wishful thinking but it is not it
is the truth that everyone knows but to
feel there to say these
days our next speaker is Mr Charlie
Ros thank you uh Mr President we were
all appalled by the images of butchered
babies and the burning of people by
Hamas sorry not all of us unfortunately
not the celebratory crowds on the
streets of Europe not mano peda of the
left who fraternized with tas's leader
isma Ania instead of being thrown out of
the left group they nominated him to the
head of the EU Parliament delegation for
Palestine and when you hear
Madame ignoring evidence that says that
they was the Palestinian Islamic Jihad
that fired that rocket that hits the
hospital you understand why don't
you and my question to the Swedish
social Democrats why are you keeping
your MP Jamal El Haj in Europe party he
protested under the banner of Hamas
worked with the Hamas linked alaka
foundation and attended a conference
with a Hamas leader he wasn't kicked out
Mr President if they on the left don't
want to be associated with anti-Semitism
terrorism and cynical electoral politics
they need to stand unequivocally with
Israel against tamas thank
you
[Applause]
Please Mr medicon Yak the floor is yours
thanks so much dear president dear
Minister Dear Mr bwell first of all I
think there is no possible way to
justify this kind of barbaric terrorist
attacks against the state of Israel and
anyone who Tred to justify that are not
better at all than those terrorists it
is not possible to justify the second
question question also from my side is
in the last four years Mr B has been in
seever several States in a neighborhood
in the Middle East but you have been not
at once in Israel while at least 20% of
the Jewish people in Israel has also the
EU passport why it's like that the third
question was for Mrs felion but of
course I understand that she has no time
to stay here to listen to debates and
also the political members from
different countries but
Hamas is officially called for Jihad all
over the world and in Europe and the
result was also on Monday evening two
days ago when one illegal terrorist
migrant killed two Swedish football fans
and this person was for years illegal in
Europe the Belgium police knew that he
is in Belgium now is the question how
many hundreds or thousands illegal
persons we have in Europe who has no
right to stay here who has no as Asylum
no legal base but they're still staying
here traveling around the Europe and
their potential draft to our security
and safety what is the number do you
know the number at least we have to know
and if you don't know you haven't done
your work and just for the last point
this war is a piece of the huge puzzle
where the cruel side is
Iran Hamas Russia and China and we have
to fight with that and we have to
understand what is the Real Enemy thank
you thank you dear colleagues we I
must I must look now to the speaking
time please accept it because we have 35
speakers in this very important debate
and it's a question of fairness of the
individual speakers to accept their own
speaking time our next speaker is Mr
Manu pinida
president but uh I do want to make a
point of order before my time starts I
don't
know why we've been told that uh we can
wear cultural and religious symbols and
I was not allowed to come out with the
Palestinian scarf it's not a flag I was
asked not to wear the Palestinian head
scarf though I don't think there any
rule that prevents that just as a point
of order now moving on to my
speech thank you president well the
first thing I'd say is that uh Mrs velan
should have had the de decency to remain
till the end of this debate because
there are things that we want to say her
to her but I'm not surprised that she
hasn't stayed because she doesn't have
that decency
the statement that Mr Burell made in am
man he was talking about something
revolutionary international law I think
it's revolutionary to call for something
which should have been a CA qua none but
uh Mrs V delion and Mrs metsola went to
Tel Aviv unconditionally supporting a
genocidal regime a regime that has
turned the Gaza Strip into something
which is very similar to the Warsaw
Ghetto they have produced a Siege in
which people are being allowed to die
without water light fuel medicines and
food and
since yesterday things have got even
worse people are dying
under Israeli bombs it's now become an
extermination camp I'd say and it is
inconceivable the speaker has been
interrupted by the
president ladies and gentlemen two
points uh I have article 10 of uh rules
of PR uh and apply that which is the
basis for a a solid debate and
secondly um Roberta uh
metula uh his visit was uh in line with
the agreement made by the uh conference
of the
presidents
and the next
speaker M Mr Nicola
Bay
the um jihadists U
have massacred young people killing
families killing children and some
people in France and even here in the
hemis refuse to say that hamus is a
terrorist group we have to understand
them as sympathizers of hamus are their
supporters uh these are people who are
not assimilated and will not be
assimilated and promoting hammers in
Europe and uh um Mrs Fel is saying that
we will triple the eight but everyone
knows that at least part of this ends up
in the pockets of hammers and uh all of
the attacks with guns with vehicles in
Brussels in Paris in Stockholm the
expression of a constant um Jihad and uh
sometimes dressed up there are uh
pretext for this but there is a single
IDE ideology attack everything that is
not um Islam and so we have no choice we
have to lead and win the the uh War it
it and we we have to control what is
said in mosques and stop uh sending
Millions to those who want to destroy
our civilizations and our people thank
you U Mel Gala you have the
floor Mr President colleagues the attack
by the Hamas terrorist uh organization
was the biggest on uh Jewish citizens
since the Holocaust I hope that it will
be possible to free the hostages and
that uh Qatar can be helpful I hope that
it will be possible to destroy the Hamas
structures in
Gaza Hamas is also a repressive corrupt
regime in
Gaza I hope that the Palestinian
Authority will be able to assume the
role of government in Gaza where the
civilians are
innocent the
responsibility uh for uh the attacks is
with Hamas not with gaza's citizens we
should uh provide humanitarian
Aid since
1999 uh this is the fourth time uh this
has happened in Gaza we need a peace
process we need the EU USA to work
together to bring the uh to bring Israel
and the Palestinians Egypt and Jordan to
the table the terrorists must not
succeed
uh thank you very much thank
you thank you very much and now uh vice
president Kina
barley colleagues uh if we listen to
some of the things that are being said
here H we could uh see think that this
might be just a spiral in the Middle
East uh but today is a break this was
the most
um lethal attack since the Holocaust and
uh it wasn't attack on the Israeli state
but it was an attack on uh children
young people at a musical festival on at
the only place where Jewish people uh
could feel uh
safe and hamus is responsible for that
apparently years uh
uh plan this for years uh but at the
same time hamus is using its own people
as a human shield they're using um water
pipes that are supposed to be used uh uh
to provide water for people as bombs um
we see that in their videos and that is
not a fight for peace it is a terror
organization uh that is killing
civilians and uh I I think uh we need to
be careful when we talk about uh uh
disinformation and um Israel has the
right to defend itself and uh that has
to be in line with International
humanitarian
law we uh need to provide Aid and we
need to make sure that uh Egypt opens
the border at rafat because there are
Vehicles there so I we calling for the
opening of that border post n thank you
very much and now Vice President Nicola
Mass the images of the massacre the
displays of people murdered who are only
murdered because they were Jews or
visiting Israel these images make
clear the
following quite
clearly it is obvious that the aim of
this uh these Terror organizations is
the
destruction of the state of Israel and
genocide against
Jews Madame or anyone who belittles or
justifies Terror against Israel against
Jews anyone who practices anti ISM or or
calls
for more
terror any
anyone who does so increases the
anti-Semitism and Terror also in our
societies we have to stop the support
for Hamas we have to make sure that
Europe is not a home for these murderers
and we have to stop this hate and uh
violence in order to have a peaceful
future we
stand alongside
Israel and now let me give the floor to
Reinhard
bofer president colle president
colleagues since the end of the
show which is always uh linked to the
name of my country there has there have
not been more people killed uh on a
single day
of Jewish faith then the uh 7th of
October with the barbaric uh attack by
Hamas in their will to destroy these
terrorists uh are following on um uh
from what the Nazis did and uh Israel
deserves our full support Israel is
defending itself it needs to defend
itself and uh EUR Europe needs to to at
least understand that U there are many
people who are
uh moved by the suffering of
Palestinians yes we do need a respecting
of uh international human rights uh law
we do need humanitarian coures but let's
not forget uh we we need uh the step uh
which will ensure that there's no uh
escalation the unconditional release of
the hostages being held by hamers and we
should be uh uh giving a warning to
Hezbollah and Iran the world uh
Community will not forget if you keep
pting oil on the
fire uh the way to peace is long but it
is possible thank you very much and now
uh Herman you have the
floor good morning thank you president
Minister High
representative we have seen the worst
killing of Jews since the Holocaust and
this has triggered a war and some people
are now complaining about the effects of
that war and they're blaming the
Jews and they
also lie once again here in this chamber
they accuse
Israel of things that others have done
which is the case when it comes to the
bombing of the hospital for example
what's happened in Gaza well there's not
a single Jew there there's no settlement
there's no Jewish or Israeli soldiers
there they haven't been there for 20
years it's the Palestinians who are in
charge
there billions have been sent there from
Europe and the United States to build it
up they could have done something good
they've got a
border with Egypt with their Muslim
friends but all they've done
is build a Cess pit of hate weapons and
destruction that's what they've done
there and we're seeing the same kind of
thing happening here in Europe our
borders are open and all those who
support Hamas are coming in and they're
also supported by a government which is
yours Minister much of your government
is supporting those who defend the
killings of Jews that's shameful for the
Spanish government and it's shameful for
Europe
Miss Anna Bon Frisco the floor is
yours thank you
president High representative Burell
colleagues
we do not say enough that there are many
Europeans who are among the victims and
hostages taken as a result of the
terrible Hamas attack there are French
citizens Italians Spanish and Germans
and I hope everything possible will be
done to free those hostages and all
hostages High representative we hope the
EU will do everything possible because
Europeans and the Jewish people share
the weight of History during these days
together we feel the pain inflicted by
Islamic
terrorism but as well as suffering we
share our Millennia old contribution to
humanity and civilization Hamas wants to
take us back to the Middle Ages and the
Palestinian people are the first
victims of Hamas the left can
ignore that these Hamas attacks in
Israel are the
worst act that the Jewish people have
suffered since the
Holocaust can they look into the eyes of
these children kidnapped by Hamas and
not be ashamed of their political
inconsistency thank you Miss Martin
M Mr President
colleagues I confess this is a difficult
speech to
make I am not speaking here on behalf of
my group I address you as a member of
the German left and I want to say that
to me it is
incomprehensible how anyone could try to
diminish or Justify hamas's terrorist
Massacre 60 Jewish and Arab Israelis
peace and human rights activists see
diminishing solidarity with victims of
the Hamas attacks among part of the
European
left and I say openly that they are
absolutely right
Hamas Terror has for years been an
obstacle to Palestinian
self-determination long before the 7th
of October Israel has the right to
defend itself that is precisely why the
EU must stop the escalation by the
doomed Netanyahu government especially a
possible ground offensive and the EU
should call for respect for
international humanitarian
law anti-Semitism on the one hand and a
refusal to talk to Palestinians on the
other are again rearing their ugly heads
in Europe in this dark hour we should
shoulder our responsibility to guarantee
Israel's right to existence and to
promote peace in the Middle East for all
sides thank you Mr Burell for for your
clear
standpoint the next speaker is Dino
J colleagues hamas's terrorist violence
their killings of civilians and the
kidnap of young people who are innocent
are a terrible thing and so it's quite
right to reiterate Israel's right to
defend itself and live in peace is quite
right to call out terrorism but that's
not enough If we're honest we have to to
say that the response to the Hamas
terrorist attack I.E cutting water and
supplies to the Palestinian
people are a major issue as well because
it prevents women men and children who
are not terrorists living in peace these
are just Palestinian human beings who
should have the right to life and to
live in peace just as Israelis have the
people of Gaza need to be supported by
in European institutions just as Israel
does let's continue the work of itak
Rabin let's call for two peoples in two
states but let's not hypocritically
close our eyes to the violence that's
being suffered by the innocent G gazan
people Palestinian people we want to see
Palestine free and we want to see Israel
free we shouldn't be looking at one side
when it comes to violations of
international law I don't want to be
ashamed of being
European
isuk the next speaker is Rasa me start
by paying respect to Brave leaders to
presidents Roberta mola and Ula VLAN I
am proud many in this chamber agree that
we must be United and agree that we have
to destroy Hamas as Al-Qaeda or Isis and
we must be United in helping Israel to
do it the destruction of Hamas would
free Israel and Palestinians from
suffering we hear slogans free Palestine
I totally agree we must free Palestine
from Hamas justifying the crimes of
Hamas is the same as justifying the
Holocaust Hamas is a tool of both Iran
and Russia these two regimes are the
source of terrorism if we don't help
Ukraine win the war as soon as possible
more fires will be set burning and the
last but not least in these terrible
Wars we must all remain
[Applause]
human thank you very much and good
morning
everybody the next speaker is Pedro
Mar
represent thank you very much Mr
President High
representative
Minister colleagues guests every year an
Israeli family organized a Peace
festival uh on the Israel Gaza border
peace messages were exchanged across the
border this year the festival was not
organized the family was murdered during
the Hamas
attack we should do our Utmost For Peace
to destroy the uh capacity of Hamas to
conduct
terrorism we should not mix Hamas with
the Palestinian people we have a legal
and moral responsibility to protect
civilians and create a lasting peace
between the two states we should not
continue with Decades of fear and
destruction G thank you and the next
speaker is Mr
geta I want to hope that we will vote
for this uh resolution unanimously
tomorrow I hope that uh despite the fact
that the text is too long far too long
because we in fact only have three
things to say the first thing is is that
we are
revulsed uh what happened and that's
secondly that the punishment for a crime
cannot be a collective p and the third
thing is that such horror even more
yesterday evening uh means that the
Palestinians and Israelis need to uh
start uh negotiations without delay uh
to move towards a two-state solution but
colleagues our
uh duty is to impose the
negotiations to uh offer everyone a uh
Safety and Security guarantees and to
say that we are uh willing to review our
trade agreements and Aid if a everyone
uh refuses the compromises that will be
necessary to end this 100-year war in
this Parliament uh there shouldn't be uh
Pro Palestinians or pro- Israelis within
the European Parliament there should
only be those supporting peace uh a fair
and Lasting
peace
Mar thank you very much thank next
speaker
Margaret well yes thank you president
thank you high representative well it
doesn't matter who was guilty of the
bombing yesterday it was a terrible
event but we shouldn't forget
that Gaza is completely closed off at
the moment nothing can get
in children and
adults have been bombarded in the Gaza
Strip during recent days and we have to
react to that
somehow if we condemn
that but we also condemn Hamas for what
it's been doing I mean we have to note
that both sides have broken
international law both both sides should
respect international law so we have a
massive challenge in Europe we have to
work towards a proper peace but we have
a
responsibility here for the fact that
nothing has happened over the last 30
years we've
spoken we've said all sorts of things
but nothing has been done to move
towards a solution this two State
solution today we have to send
out a
message we need a full and comprehensive
peace and we have
to act to ensure that we get the result
that we so desire
because we don't help anyone if we don't
find a solution thank
you thank you very much M K many
innocent people including children will
never see the sunrise again because they
were Jewish in
2023 they were slaughtered by hammers
that a colleague MP of Miss auri called
a move movement of resistance on the
French radio yesterday Hamas is an
Islamic terrorist organization that
still holds Israeli and foreign hostages
today in addition to the population of
Gaza itself that it uses as a human
shield against any Israeli military
response worse than is it and not so far
from us again another teacher was killed
in France again innocent citizens were
shot in Brussels in the name of Allah
and yet we as Europe keep making the
same mistakes dear colleagues radical
Islam is progressing because we are not
recognizing it as it is I worry about
the Jews I worry about innocent
Palestinians I worry about Europe I
worry about our civilization and the
loss of the feeling we all identify as
safety when in our European cities
demonstration shout death to Israel and
death to Jews then it's no longer a
demonstration but death threats threats
against you here and everywhere else and
against our Western Civilization the EU
must fix its migration policy control
where its money goes call radical Islam
by its name reject any in infiltration
and also we must realize the people of
Brussels do not need candles and
commemoration they need protection thank
you thank you very much colleagues
please stick to the allocated time next
speaker syvia Lio
colleagues the Cowardly Massacre by
Palestinian Hamas of Israeli civilians
is an attack on our Western Civilization
on values like uh tolerance and
coexistence it's an attack on our
religious Legacy and yet yet here in the
EU all we hear is hollow
words on the side of
Israel this is a horrific uh attack and
what you are missing is that it is
the uh Arabic Muslim Palestinian
Lebanese Syrian and above all Iranian
Mulla hate that wants to do away with
the state of
Israel it
is it it is a moral bankr bankruptcy of
leftwing
anti-Semitism uh that we see in the EU
and I'm ashamed of it
completely Chris McManus thank you Chris
McManus please thank you chair here and
firstly I want to express my deepest
sympathy and condolences to the family
of Irish woman Kim damy and All Families
who've lost loved ones whether they be
Israeli or Palestinian there is no
justification for the killing of
civilians by either Hamas or Israel we
must also condemn the forc displacement
by Israel of Palestinians in clear
breach of international humanitarian law
and the cutting off of water fuel food
and medical supplies and the destruction
of Civilian infrastructure throughout
Gaza which amounts to Collective
punishment in contention of
international humanitarian law to
achieve deescalation we need rigorous
impartial International Leadership so to
president vand deryan your actions are a
crucial reminder why unanimity must be
retained on foreign security and defense
policy particularly for neutral
countries like
Ireland finally Following last night's
horrific Hospital attack there is an
urgent need for an immediate ceasefire
and to formulate an effective road map
Pro providing for a proper negotiations
process based on unconditional adherence
to international law and the UN Charter
only then can we begin to ensure a
durable and just solution to the
Palestinian question
G
Frances thank you Franchesca Donato now
please well thank you
president Israel is at War and now we've
seen a hospital in Gaza City struck by a
rocket and that's increased the numbers
of
victims accusations are flying between
Hamas and Israel as to where this rocket
came from and we're going to have to
investigate that properly so that we can
prevent propaganda and
speculation but nevertheless now we have
to 100% stand by Israel they're fighting
with their men and women against the
worst form of terrorism because there
can never be a Palestinian State nor
peace between the two peoples as long as
Hamas
exists we need to help the Palestinian
population and Palestinian civilians but
we also need to protect Israelis and we
need to help the Israeli government in
what they're doing we need to check very
carefully where we're sending European
funds to ensure that tunnels aren't
being built and terrorists aren't being
funded and we're also going to have to
take clear measures to prevent other
terrorists coming into Europe via
migration
channels this is our responsibility
thank
you Daniel thank you Danielle Caspar now
please
uh the attack cannot be justified Israel
has a right to defend itself and to
protect its population I have no
understanding for how some uh uh people
are standing up and criticizing Israel
uh Israel despite the advantage
disadvantages that it brings is trying
to protect its citizens if those people
are criticizing isra they need to call
on Hammer to release uh the uh hostages
and not to be hiding uh Munitions and
the like in civilian bottles and uh
keeping
civilians and what I thought was very
good in Europe it we had uh the um the
visits by our um commission and uh
Parliament president but these were
quick and I I found it very strange um
High Representatives that you criticized
the president for that visit I think it
is important that in these difficult
times uh we are united and we keep any
criticism uh to ourselves within our own
homes and Israel and all of the peac
loving
um people in the area need to be
supported so that there is finally peace
in the region thank
[Applause]
you R Ben Rando Ben now
please thank you president High
representative we have condemned the
massacre carried out by the terrorists
of Hamas and we have reiterated Israel's
sacran right to defend itself and
neutralize the capacity of the
terrorists and we've also called for the
immediate release of all the hostages
but we cannot see Revenge being carried
out in Gaza we're seeing a massive
humanitarian disaster take place and we
can't be quiet given that cutting water
and electricity is a violation of
international law and it's also doing a
favor to Hamas and Iran because they
want to feed a spiral of unending
destruction what we need to do is
isolate the terrorists and their
supporter and fight the return of
hateful forms of anti-semitism and work
towards an end of the bombardments we
need to see the restoration of a
diplomatic process that can restore hope
to the Israeli and Palestinian people
after years of fear Terror and illegal
occupation the European Union needs to
do its share of the work for
peace thank you our next speaker is
MRI strongly and and I strongly attack
the
ATT the attacks by Hammers and there are
people on the left uh who aren't doing
it but
uh they are those on the right who are
not condemning the um dispropor my
ancestors were uh fought against the
Nazis and they gave their life uh to uh
liberate my country France
and if they didn't collaborate with the
right so do not take this situation and
make it a a war of uh
civilizations that's exactly what the
terrorists want they want war to spread
everywhere H we are built on an Ideal of
peace and we need to bring that message
to everyone and Europe is not doing that
the moment it is not being hurt uh the
world is deteriorating without us having
any influence whatsoever
Mr VRA
please ladies and
gentlemen
complexity and the insoluble nature of
what's happening in the Middle East must
not deprive us of the understanding of
what is essential what we saw last week
is in fact black and white it's a
barbarian attack on our civilization an
attack by those who want death against
those who love life it's an attack on
people with devilish goals who kill uh
abduct rape women and use their own
people as human
Shields what is happening over there
isn't about Palestinians it's about
Hamas it's about terrorists it's about
those who deny Israel everything right
up to the right of existence and we have
one
task we should stand firmly on the St on
the side of
[Applause]
Israel
phip Philip de man now
please thank
you thank you president colleagues uh
you're shocked by the outbreak of hate
in Israel in France in
Brussels but colleagues you're
subsidizing hate you're importing hate
the uh subsidies that you give uh from
the uh EU budget 1.2 billion
uh and uh in another year 2.1 uh in
development age to Palestine and
why because
um
it because you're importing hate CH and
Afghan and Palestines are uh being let
in to Europe and
why uh couldn't uh they go to their U
Islamic Brothers in the uh in the
um Oil States
and and what what about the attack on uh
uh zum H how many more people need to
die before you finally open your
eyes Mr rovski next
please colleague
there is no chosen people or indeed a a
not chosen people we are all chosen by
God because we live on one
Earth it will never
be possible to destroy the Jewish Nation
but nor will it ever be possible to
destroy the longsuffering Palestinian
Nation my question is this why do we
only want to to give the Jewish people
the right to live in their own country
why not the Palestinians why do we have
double standards
when solving
problems all
attacks on uh
women
uh INF
structure are unjustifiable on either
side I agree with Mr
Borel I agree with Russia and
China the
basis for a definitive resolution is the
two-state solution the creation of an
independent Palestinian State thank
you
thank you our next speaker is
y it is quite clear to any European what
Hamas is
doing we have to defend Europe with
whatever we can Europe is B based on
judeo-christian
values it
is vital to uh stop uh terrorism it must
uh not take
root we
should not uh get lost in uh political
infighting we have teachers killed in uh
France at terrorist attack in Brussels
attacks on London Brussels
Paris Madrid we had the 11th of
September in New York I think it's quite
clear uh what is
happening Israel is uh legitimate in
defending its people it is absolutely
right to carry on what it has
started we
should uh verify what is happening to
the money we are giving to the
Palestinians it's quite clear that this
money is not only being used for
humanitarian
purposes we have to help populations in
need the microphone has been cut
off thank you thank you very much your
time is
over olon Karina
pleas
president Israeli civilians uh were
injured and
killed men women and
children and uh we firmly condemn uh the
Hamas attack against Israel and uh uh
Israel has the right to defend itself
and to rescue the hostages but um Israel
also has uh human rights obligations
towards the civilian from the
Palestinian CI civilian should not be
punished yesterday evening we heard that
hundreds uh died in an attack on a
hospital in Gaza and that is
unacceptable or any attacks against
um civilian installations must be
condemned uh there needs to be access to
food and to water and medicines and uh
the EU has said that it wants to Triple
Aid we welcome that uh as snd we need uh
support uh for those who are fighting
for peace and for
Humanity
mras thank you president let me
unequivocally condemn the terrible acts
carried out by Hamas and I'd like to see
the hostages fully and immediately
freed secondly we have to clearly state
that the punishment that Israel is
inflicting on the Gaza Strip is
collective punishment and it's a war
crime cutting electricity Water and
Light to millions of people is illegal
and should be cond demed by the European
Union we have to call for an in speak
out against that we have to also call
for an investigation on with regard to
the bombing on the hospital yesterday
now I didn't understand why the
president of the commission and the
president of this
Parliament to Israel who were they
speaking on behalf of were they speaking
on behalf of us they weren't speaking on
behalf of the millions of Europeans who
want to see a fair and just solution for
peace we need a ceasefire urgently and
we need to renew peace talks which can
lead to the two- stat solution which we
all know is the only viable solution to
this conflict thank
you vinski thank you Mr vinsky now
please thank you
sir thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen the greens and the left uh uh
uh those sympathizing with hammer and do
you really think that this is the the
time uh to uh
triple support because this money is
going to have us who have all all these
stockpiles of weapons just as it is
absur that yesterday um
president Michelle said that uh Europe
would help in deescalation that that is
uh the the same uh organization that's
uh then getting their um people are sent
from Brussels to Strasburg and they end
up in Euro Desi um and
over8 years it hasn't been uh possible
uh
for to deal with the water situation
that is the European Union and it is it
is failing it's failing uh in Ukraine
and now it it's uh fra and it's in fact
inflaming the conflict by providing
These funds
uh talk here about peace and that is
what you need to talk about and don't
talk about uh doing things that you're
not able to do thank you thank you very
much colleague uh bofer you got a point
of
Auto thank you president I have a point
order the speaker willimsky just said
that my group sympathizes with Hamas
all speakers of our group have said
exactly the opposite it cannot be
allowed that such lies are spread in the
European
Parliament thank you very much the point
is made I give the floor toor
de thank you president or the images of
Destruction suffering and death caused
by the worrying escalation of violence
in the Middle East require us to reflect
peace cannot be built with terrorism or
with violence the serious attack by
Hamas has reignited Decades of complex
of political complexity and Regional
violence the Middle East process
requires a committed approach which
involves International diplomacy I.E
Europe as well we need constructive
dialogue which is the only way to
achieve a lasting and sustainable peace
in the interests of everyone involved
including the global Community we'd like
today to reiterate our commitment to a
two-state solution two states for two
peoples where Security on both sides is
respected we need to work towards a
future in which dialogue comprehension
and respect replace conflict and
violence because as you all know
violence is not a
solution violence leads only to losers
and many innocent
victims Danika now
please thank you very much Mr president
vice president Chev choic High
representative barell Minister we are
here to say something very clear Hamas
terrorism must stop we all saw the
horrors we all saw the images of the
massacres committed in Israel we saw the
uh babies killed and burned we saw what
happened to the women to the elderly
people as a result of Hamas
terrorism appalling unacceptable things
have happened and I want to tell you
something the hundreds of people have
been taken
hostage uh people's children have been
killed they one of them thanked God for
the fact that his child had been killed
because it saved her from uh torture by
Hamas we have seen what happens what
what terrorism means the destruction of
families through this unjustified
appalling violence Hamas terrorism must
stop terrorism in Brussels must stop
terrorism in France must
stop Sergey linski Sergey linski
now my wholehearted condolences to the
victims and all those affected by the
destruction of the Al Ali Arabi Hospital
in Gaza no matter how many victims they
were because even one person's life is a
human life it is tragic that missiles of
Islamic Jihad and Hamas are flying over
the heads of Those whom Hamas has made
to their hostages and by that I don't
mean Israelis I mean Palestinians it is
tragic that instead of investing into
water and sewage systems water pipes are
used to produce missiles Machinery to
kill to kill the others and sometimes to
kill One's Own It it is unimaginable
pain to look at photos of Israeli
victims it is tragic that Israel has no
choice but defend itself and yes defend
itself by military because Hamas leaves
Israel no other options this war started
with Hamas in humanity this will war
will end through Israel's Humanity
because yes it is human deeply human to
try to provide security to your
civilians but it also human to do the
outmost possible to limit the
humanitarian losses in Gaza to look for
peaceful solution beyond the current
operation and yes look for a peaceful
solution with Palestinians ultimately
this time is now time for our commonness
in Europe without hatred without hatred
on the streets and without us trying to
get political benefits from supporting
the masses chanting for terrorists we
need to stand together even if it is
very very hard to be able to
stand
[Applause]
Mr bam now
please Israel has been struck to its
heart the attacks have left our
continent in mourning and but even today
we're hearing speeches that leave us
chilled to the Bone we've heard about
people talking about war
crimes in Rel ation to hamas's attacks
but words have meaning colleagues and
that means that Hamas is a proper Army
if you say that and it means that
there's coll collateral damage but no
those attacks were organized by a
terrorist organization a terrorist
islamist organization and their goal was
to kill as many civilians as possible
they were killing people because they
were Israelis they were killing Jews
because they were Jews is it so
difficult to say that those who want to
defend the Palestinians in Gaza need to
start by condemning
Hamas they are those who are causing
this endless tragedy for
civilians what chills us is to see the
fact that leftwing politicians have
chosen to close their eyes to everything
that we should be defending through hate
and for electoral purposes they've
closed their eyes to this hate we're
seeing in our countries and acoss Ross
the world they need to be able to
condemn it in an unnuanced and clear
manner because otherwise they'll be
failing in our historic responsibility
thank you
um Mr B you got a a blue card from um
our colleague
um
de
you I'll be speaking German well thank
you very much president thank you Mr
bellany Bellamy for allowing me to ask
this question now I have several times
from colleagues from your party that the
left are speaking in favor or uh playing
down Hamas
actions Etc that's what you've said said
but are you aware that the left in the
Muslim world are those that are fighting
against terrorist reactionary
actions we are not the brothers of
Islamic reactionaries it's fascist
forces in Europe that are doing that so
please stop making that comparison it's
leftwing and Progressive forces in
Arabic Arab countries that are calling
for Brotherhood and peace thank
you Mr bellam now colleagues
colleague rather it's not me you should
be asking you should ask that question
of colleagues in your political group
why do they refuse to say that Hamas is
a terrorist organization why even today
are they refusing to say that on the 7th
October what happened was a widescale
terrorist attack why are they refusing
to use those words why are they refusing
to say
what's clear we're seeing Jews targeted
because they're Jews and given that we
should all together clearly denounce it
with a single voice why are they not
doing that with us
[Applause]
today toas now
please
yesterday the other day we heard about
another terrorist attack in
Brussels and we saw the effects of
Terror on the 7th of October when Hamas
conducted a barbaric attack on Israel
Israel has a right to defend
itself the social Democrats talk about
peace and yes we want
peace but then you should stand up for
the only democracy in the Middle East
and defend its right to defend itself
against Hamas Terror there are 200
Israeli
hostages uh children women and men who
are being held in
Gaza um
asopos Mrs as mop please after four and
a half years in this house we know each
other's positions on Israel and
Palestine quite well in this moment we
need to rise above these positions and
we need to speak in one voice to condemn
the Despicable attack on Israel by
terrorist group Hamas to recognize
Israel's unequivocal right to
self-defense and Israel has my vote of
confidence that this will be done and is
being done in accordance with
international law
to call for the immediate and
unconditional release of hostages to
protect innocent civilians to prevent a
humanitarian crisis today the European
Parliament has a choice we can exploit
this resolution for political gain and
become even more entrenched in our
respective positions or we can use this
resolution to Champion unity and in
doing so lead by example after all if we
cannot overcome our differences to
combat terrorism then when can we thank
[Applause]
you ultimate interven Andre our last
speaker is Andre k please High
representative Minister commissioner
dear colleagues few clear points I
strongly condemn the threatful terrorist
attack that Hamas carried out against
Israel Israel has the right to defend
itself against terrorism ensuring in
international law combating terrorism
not targe the Palestinian civil
population we must recognize and support
this right while striving for a peaceful
resolution the fight against terrorism
is also our fight in the EU while the
war against Hamas is taking place the EU
must continue to provide humanitarian
Aid to
the population of Palestine at the same
time we need to ensure that in no way EU
funding directly or indirectly support
the activities of Hamas or other
terrorist organization we cannot allow
resources me for the essential needs of
Palestinians to be diverted to the
violence purposes I strongly urge the
immediate and unconditional release of
all hostages it is inhumane to use
innocent lives and as bargaining chips
and it I fully condemn this practice
lastly it is essential to acknowledge
and denounce the role of external
actions in this actors in this conflict
the involvement of Iran in in training
and funding Hamas as well the
involvement of pro Kremlin forces in the
physical support of Hamas and in the
spread of propaganda and disinformation
supporting Hamas further comp complicate
the situation and cannot be accepted
anymore thank you very
much thank you very much we come now to
the catdi procedure as you know we have
vot votes at um
12:00 uh but fortunately we only have 36
Road requests under the catdi procedure
as you can imagine I cannot give the
floor to all of you far from that but
let's do our best please stick to the
allocated time let's begin with uh Zana
zco she's not in the room okay so uh
then uh the next on the list is Tomy
sool
thank you on the 7th of October this
year the terrorist group Hamas committed
the biggest crime in the history of
Israel Over
1,400 civilians mostly women and seniors
were killed in the most brutal way mass
murders unfortunately are not something
that Israel
uh Israelis hadn't experienced before
um I actually fear um to think what
would have Israelis uh experience had
they lost at least one of the wars that
they had waged um terrorists have been
killing uh um people in Europe in the
streets for years now illegal uh
migrants uh celebrate hamas's crime in
uh the camps I see that some people here
are trying to equalize the blame and
speak in relative terms of what has
happened there are no butts about it the
exclusive culprit for what has happened
is Hamas that massacred civilians and is
still using civilians as a living sheet
ladies and gentlemen it is a Humane and
normal thing to support Israel to defend
itself of course with a respect of all
aspects of the humanitarian uh law also
we have to protect the security of of
our citizens and do so without excuses
thank you uh Milan
Bas thank you for giving me the
floor I uh condemn the terrorist acts of
Hamas that were done against Israeli
citizens I condemn the atrocities of
Israel against the Palestinian civilist
civilians there are
no ways
to support
this
Israel has uh done atrocities as well
which cannot be justified simply because
Hamas uh is done a terrorist attack we
need to be on the side of the victims we
cannot uh differentiate between victims
they all deserve our compassion help and
support we have to use all means to
prevent these atrocities to continue but
for that we need a diplomatic and peace
process the two-state solution and uh to
bring the
responsible in front of the
international criminal court that was
established also with the help of the
European member states next speaker
Barry
Andreas uh thank you president I'd like
to begin by condemning the atrocities
carried out by Mass including the
ongoing hostage taking and Sheltering
military assets at our near c key
civilian infrastructure I assert the
right of Israel to defend itself a right
based in international law specifically
the UN Charter but that same
international law H specifically forbids
forced population transfer Collective
punishment and indiscriminate targeting
uh including targeting of a civilian
infrastructure international law is all
that protects Humanity in our darkest
hours I was astonished that President
verion didn't take the opportunity to
acknowledge the confused Communications
from the European commission and the
Damage that's done to our credibility
the the European Union should now
support the UN call for an immediate
humanitarian ceasefire and humanitarian
Corridor and take advantage of the
global attention on this crisis for a
real political initiative to bring peace
to the region and end the cycle of
violence thank
you thank you than you very much next
speaker Anna
Miranda president F how is it possible
that you got involved in the way you did
you took a partisan position rather than
being neutral and negotiating for peace
is the most important thing flying the
Israeli flag in Brussels and visiting
Netanyahu or shouldn't it be criticizing
what's happening in Gaza V Mrs V delion
you should resign bombing of hospitals
citizens uh cutting off water supplies
Etc these are crimes against
humanity Europe is being hypocritical
but you can't be hypocritical in our
name there are several resolutions from
the United
Nations supporting the Palestinian
people and they're not being respected
that's
deplorable Collective punishment is
being carried out on the Palestinian
people and there are people who are just
calling for self-determination I fully
reject the genocide in Gaza and the
ethnic CLE cleansing being carried up by
Israel in Palestine we call for a
ceasefire humanitarian corridors and the
immediate application of international
humanitarian law we need to work
tirelessly for the cessation of violence
in Gaza and a peaceful solution we do
not want to see any more people dead
whatever their nationality we do not
want to see this genocide in Gaza and we
don't want it uh not in our name
certainly thank you chair the
communication of the EU on the
atrocities committed by Hamas were a
mess president thion as she has done on
multiple occasions overstretched her
mandate while I personally commend her
support for Israel she bypassed the
leaders of the member States
Representative Morell did the same and I
would like to add that his position on
this one is very very sketchy apparently
it is difficult to even stand up for
Israel with one voice according to my
book if you stand for the rule of law
democracy and freedom you support Israel
unconditionally the communication
failure by the commission shows again
that a common European foreign policy is
a fiction a paper tiger a dud why
because there is not one EU foreign
policy please stop acting like there is
one and defund the external Action
Service
immediately thank you very much next
speaker Marisa
Matias thank you very much
um I I fully condemn uh the barbarism of
the terrorism attacks by um but uh we
have to call for the same rigor when we
talk about the crimes against humanity
which were committed by Israel why is
the suffering of the Palestinian people
uh not the same as the suffering of um
Israeli people uh Collective punishment
being imposed uh on uh people uh how
many innocent people are going to have
to die uh um occupa
uh cutting off the water cutting off
electricity um Force displacement these
are all uh clear violations of a
humanitarian law we need to call for the
uh Liberation all of the Israeli hostage
of course but there needs to be a
ceasefire and an end of the uh
bombardments against the civilian
population thank you
to thank you chair first let me Express
that I strongly condemn the brutal
terrorist attacks carried out by hamus
and I acknowledge Israel's rights to
self-defense in line with international
law my thoughts and prayers are with the
families of the victims in these
difficult times it is important to
highlight that the current conflict
caused by the terrorist attack can lead
to the
destabilization of the entire Middle
Eastern region and jeopardize the Prest
process generated by the Abraham eorts
therefore in my opinion the only
solution to prevent any future
Interstate conflict is through
deescalation policy and to return to the
positive changes that were made
previously it is shocking to see how
many pro Terror demonstrations and
sympathy rallies supporting the
terrorist are taking place throughout
Western Europe as terror is unacceptable
I would like to recall that in Hungary
no one is allowed to hold demonstrations
promoting the cause of terrorist
organizations thank
you thank you very much so now I will
allow three more uh speakers only
beginning with andreus
kilius dear
colleagues it is not enough to say that
Israeli has a right to defend it itself
our position should be very clear Hamas
needs to be destroyed and eliminated as
terrorist organization and that should
be done not only by Israeli but by all
the Democratic Community there is no
another way like it was done with Isis
and Al-Qaeda second in our war against
terrorism the life of civilians should
be protected humanitarian assistance for
civilians should be provided but there
is no way how Hamas can be destroyed in
a peaceful way there is no Miracle
Solution there will be collateral damage
and victims but that is the price of our
war against terrorism today alternative
is very clear either we shall destroy
terrorism or terrorism will destroy
us much next speaker Costas
mavrides thank you
president today we condemn the
Despicable Hamas terrorist attacks no
excuses no tolerance today we stand in
line with the right of Israel for
self-defense today we say clearly and
strongly jihadist Hamas is not
Palestine given that Israel is a
democratic state I'm appealing once
again to the new Unity government to
accept the jurisdiction of the
international criminal court
so that humanitarian law prevails and
serves as a deterrent for any war crimes
or crimes against humanity as far as
last night's bombardment of the hospital
whoever is responsible or are
responsible intentionally or not they
have innocent BL on their hands that's
why we should leave politics aside and
stay with International law and the
right of for self-defense for
Israel thank you very much now I give
the floor to Frederick
RI thank you Mr President never
again that was the promise to the
survivors of aitz and banal never again
that was the promise of the founding
fathers who built what they built on the
ruins
the the 7th of
October uh prgram was uh the worst since
the uh Holocaust but what is vital is
that we call things by their proper name
this was a vicious terrorist
attack uh
14400 to 1500 victims in
Israel it's very important for us to get
our words right silence
kills whether it's in whether it's over
there or in Aras or in
Brussels it is vital now to rebuild hope
very
much we come now to the closing
statements um starting with vice
president of the European commission
maros
seich thank you very much Mr President
Mr Minister High representative uh
honorable members of the European
Parliament we are about to conclude one
of the the most
important and most emotional debates in
this
hemicycle and rightly so because it just
demonstrates our shock and horror over
Hamas terrorist attacks in Israel and
the terrorist attacks here in Europe in
Belgium and in France and I clearly felt
that we are united in the condemnations
in the strongest POS ible
terms of Hamas and its brutal terrorist
attacks our debate also underline our
compassion our compassion for innocent
civilian victims in Israel and Gaza and
I very much appreciate your overwhelming
support for the right of Israel to
self-defense in line with the
international humanitarian
law we in the commission hear you loud
and C clear when you call for addressing
humanitarian crisis in
Gaza humanitarian Aid must urgently
reach Palestinians we tripled our
humanitarian Aid to civilians in Gaza we
open EU airbridge to Egypt and our staff
to whom I would like to thank for the
dedication and service is already on the
ground to work with un agencies to
ensure that this Aid can reach those in
need
honorable members we also hear you loud
and clear when you call for unrelenting
diplomacy in a moment for Minister
Alvarez and high representative Borel
will address you I can assure you that
we will spare no effort to work for
release of hostages taken by barbaric
Hamas and fight terrorism everywhere in
the Middle East in Europe or in wider
world but we also hear you loud and
clear when you state that the
indiscriminate and brutal terrorist
attacks against Israel and its people by
Hamas directly threaten peace and
Security in the region and also the way
how you underline the need for renewed
efforts to reinvigorate the Middle East
peace process as you know very well the
EU is first and foremost peace project
therefore it's clear that remain
strongly committed to Lasting and
sustainable peace in the Middle Eastern
region thank
you thank
you very
much now I give the floor to minister
zanu
harz
graas thank you very much indeed
president president of the commission
High
representative we are poised to conclude
this debate at a time which is so
serious for the whole world and our
friends throughout the globe as well as
our Citizens need to stand United in
firmly condemning the terrorist
attack sustained by Israel and its right
to defend itself at the present time as
well as on the need
to defend international law and to
preserve and Safeguard the civilian
population as well as calling for the
immediate and unreserved release of all
our compatriots Ivan arendi and
also making sure
that humanitarian assistance can be
afforded to the Palestinian people as
well as what they need to survive the
European Union of
course rallies around those principles
because they underpin our European
political identity and that is why it is
so important that we all understand that
one cannot conflate Hamas which is
merely a terrorist organization with the
legitimate leadership of the Palestinian
people which for decades now has been
our partner for for
peace if we undermine that Authority
then that would be delerious not only
for the Palestinians also for the
Israelis and for ourselves and that is
why the Spanish government is going to
step up its assistance to the
Palestinian Authority as well as to unra
and all of the Civil Society
organizations because we cannot
countenance anybody exploiting this
tragedy for their own personal ends here
today one of the Spanish MEPS spread
untruths about the robust stand of the
Spanish government at this time it
behoves us all to behave with the
highest degree of responsibility to
contribute to deescalate the tension and
to do our bit to Foster dialogue because
all of us wish to avoid any expansion of
the conflict we have a clear United
Nations framework and the Spanish
government stands for square behind that
framework and that is why we must stand
with all of our Arab friends in the
region there was another plea that I
heard
today in the chamber repeatedly and one
which I echoed repeatedly in my
introductory statement and that is that
we try to push for a two-state
solution an Israeli and a Palestinian
state which recognize one another as
neighbors as partners for prosperity and
which would also enjoy recognition from
the International Community let's get
down to work and let's make that a
reality and let's make a reality of
Peace in the Middle East thank you very
much thank you very much Minister for
your intervention on behalf of the
Spanish presidency and now to conclude
our debate I give the floor to vice
president and the high representative
Jose Burell you got the
floor thank you Mr President thank you
to all the members that has
participated in this
debate ladies and gentlemen a couple of
days ago a couple of weeks ago actually
I was in babiar
babiar is an area close to Kiev in
Ukraine where in
1941 the
Nazis executed 30
33,700 plus individuals they took them
there making them to believe that they
were going to take that they were going
to leave for Palestine and when they
arrived at babiar they simply shot them
uh H those along with numerous other
hundreds of thousands of people died
during the Nazi occupation of
Ukraine I shared a moment of
remembrance with the rabbi which keeps
alive the flame of memory of
babiar
and I said what I said nothing appears
to me more horrific than to murder
people because because they they pertain
to some religious group some confession
some group in
general be it Jew Muslim
Christian we are all human beings and in
Europe we've made this one of this is
this is
our to reject that which what the
Holocaust was and the whole ideology
behind it so this memory and in our
terrible conscience with regard to this
because it
was we some of
us that conducted these acts now this
moment in babiar at
nighttime recognizing the terrible
burden of guilt that we bear Vis A the
Jewish people and in expressing our
support as well for the state of Israel
and I say that to all those who believe
that when uh a a a tragedy that one
tragedy is more uh terrible than another
to reject both tragedies no there's a
type
of of distancing if you like from
suffering from the suffering of the
people of
Israel of now and
before so what took place uh these days
what has taken place these days in
Israel was a terrible shock for the
people of Israel Terri terrible
indeed
1,300 dead in one day it is the most
terrible event since the second in in
2000 for the state of Israel
1,300 when you uh take that in
proportional figures that would be uh
thousands more in France for
example so you can understand the
seriousness of this issue so so uh
Israel has not an exper not experienced
a moment of trauma of such depth in the
recent past one of the most Darkest Days
in the Palestinian Israeli conflict and
it is the beginning of a new chapter in
this conflict as well we could say that
we are entering the
fifth
chapter uh although there have been two
projects
uh up until
now in the beginning of the 1990s for
reconciliation that is and then a second
one but that was followed by uh
confrontation until 20 46 and then the
conventional Wars between Israel and the
Israeli States between 46 and 86 and
then the fourth Act of this tragedy the
rep palestin isation of the conflict as
is said by academics the inata the
various rebellions the the the
negotiations between fat and Yak Rabin
in Oslo with the Oslo Accords now we're
entering this fifth stage that may be
darker than all the previous if the
International Community does not stop
this and the International Community has
to do something because it was the
International Community that has uh
created this entire stage to a certain
extent of this conflict Since U the
United
Nations
uh decided in in the 1947
1948 a division the Palestinian mandate
the whole division that took place in
that area the establishment of the
borders and the security Council uh
resolutions that said that stated quite
clearly what ought to be done and what
not to be done so it's international law
which is the only source of a common
language which allows us to deal with
this particular conflict because the
first thing that we need is a Common
Language otherwise it is not possible to
have any sort of dialogue whatsoever so
history has shown us that the most
difficult decisions are taken when we're
at the edge of the abis and I think
we're at that point right now ladies and
gentlemen uh when we hear uh religious
Muslims speaking about the
interreligious conflict and mentioning
specifically Europe on this point as
part of this particular conflict it
makes me feel that we have a terrible
storm what that is before us that we
must
stop and and you saw how this has all
been swirled into emotion as well going
Beyond emotion
actually and we will not be able to
resolve this conflict until we come to
our senses so let's not correct an error
with another error or attempt to do that
we have false descriptions of what's
taking place fake news and we're trying
to uh we're trying to really understand
now what is manipulation and what isn't
not error with
error not those who have been
decapitated because this is information
which has not been confirmed and
actually that has been confirmed by the
Israeli Army as well so the Western
world has to kind of step back because
there are we don't need to make another
mistake there are already enough
mistakes that have been made out
there because to kill 1,300 people in 24
hours you have to go and try to find
them in their places of hiding in the
most bloody fashion so you don't need to
add anything more to
that we have enough with what has
already happened but in the same way
that we can say that is an abominable
tragedy to kill
270 individuals who are celebrating life
we can't say that
it's that it's not less of a tragedy for
780 plus children to die under bombs
that have been dropped on uh Gaza
so uh so you you simply have to be able
to all this together and understand so
to condemn one thing that ability I have
that to is if I can condemn something
which is equally terrible which is done
by other people which may be actually
closer to me and if we don't understand
this we cannot be useful in order to try
to resolve this horrific conflict and
for that reason I'd also like to tell
you stop saying that we are subsidizing
Hamas terrorism stop saying that with
our money we're
paying uh for the social system that
goes to Palestinians which have been
convicted of crimes that is not true we
have a system of control of monitoring
where our money goes and it works well
we control where our resources are going
and it's at the disposal of the
commission you can take a look at it but
stop saying things that are not true
because quite to the contrary it just
simply agitates the whole atmosphere of
the
situation and allow me to say that the
criticism why I haven't gone to Israel
that's been exercised up until now why
haven't I gone up until now I think um I
am one of the European politicians that
has done most in order to deal with the
situation in
Israel and the meeting of the
association council with Israel
uh which many many years 10 years which
has not taken place it simply hasn't met
and I uh pushed for this to take place
because I felt it was absolutely
necessary to have dialogue with the
Israeli government at this point in time
and I've spoken a number
of occasions with the Ministers of
Foreign Affairs for them to come to
Brussels and they've done that to
discuss this
issue I've taken major initiatives in
order to relaunch the peace effort in
the United Nations more
specifically uh with unra as well
present and also uh we had established
dates and deadlines and I do hope to be
able to move forward but uh fundamental
conditions if I'm to visit Israel would
mean that I would also be able to visit
ramala the West Bank so uh with the
emotion of the days that we've uh had uh
I think well it's it's not only by going
there that one uh occupies oneself with
the problems and I don't criticize
anybody that's done that and I will not
be uh drawn into some sort of
interinstitutional debate because what
we need here is a concerted e effort we
need to work
together Hamas is a terrorist
organization it has to be fought and
Israel has the right to defense and it
has to be able do this defense if you
like within the framework of
international la and we have a lot to
work on in this particular direction so
as soon as we've accepted this premise
we'll be able to work together more
effectively so I hope to be able to
visit Israel
but I can't tell
you uh what the member states have to
say and with their
uh they've communicated with the
countries of the gulf that they uh
suspend the various uh Provisions for
water I'm sorry that is contrary to
international law but uh we can't do
that we cannot do this we cannot accept
these things as such things have to be
taken into consideration when we
evaluate this conflict and look at the
dictionary of
uh humanitarian practice that uh the
provision of water and depriving a
community of water goes contrary to
International law in Ukraine and in Gaza
as well and if we're not able to do that
or to uh in both places indeed we lose
that moral Authority if we're not able
to really underscore and emphasize this
thank you very much representative
Bell I have uh received seven motions
for resolution to wind up this debate
the debate is now closed and the vote
will be held uh tomorrow dear colleagues
I have two short announcements to make
miss Monica benova and Miss Karina Ro
n sorry
nadova are no longer members of the snd
group and they sit with the non-attached
members as of October 18th
2023 miss Monica benova has also
resigned from her office uh of quer with